son las fuerzas especiales integradas en
el batallón de azov una nueva división
que lucha en primera línea y en las
operaciones más expuestas de la guerra
de ucrania entrenan en distintas
localizaciones para evitar ser
descubiertos
trabajamos como un grupo de
reconocimiento y sabotaje nuestra tarea
es destruir equipos mano de obra y minas
limpiar minas realizar reconocimientos
dirigir la artillería o liberar pueblos
si la situación lo requiere podemos
llevar a cabo la defensa de pueblos
un batallón polémico por su pasado
paramilitar de líderes ultra
nacionalistas y extremistas que utilizan
símbolos nazis su comandante lo niega
estas son las fantasías de algunas
personas sobre el hecho de que fue
creado a partir de personas ultra
nacionalistas los miembros de la unidad
eran personas patrióticas que amaban su
país a su estado y su cultura han sido
utilizados por vladimir putin para
acusar a ucrania de nazi en numerosas
ocasiones son mediáticos saben utilizar
las redes sociales y la batalla de
lacería de mariupol ha hecho crecer su
fama
era un poco
digámoslo así se trata de una unidad de
las fuerzas armadas de ucrania todos los
participantes tienen experiencia de
combate muchos de ellos pasaron por el
as off de mariupol algunos se han
retirado google y sus new spears con el
batallón de azov sigue entrenándose
indefinidamente entre bosques y colinas
para preparar a los nuevos combatientes
que luchen en el este de ucrania